okay hi everyone this is a wolf and
language design review part of our
language completeness and consistency
series and we have a variety of topics
binding of pattern and Alternatives why
do I think there's going to be something
incredibly horrifying and hard to
understand well we talked about this
um and there was some discussion
of uh you know whether we should change
this and
um right so the issue is according to
the way the documentation is currently
worded it says that if you use a brand a
variable that only appears in a branch
that isn't the branch that matches it is
bound to sequence bracket bracket but
that's not literally true it it just
disappears completely
and you know there was some discussion
well should we make it match the
documentation or even try something else
so we did the experiment of you know
making the implementation right and it
flopped right like plot was broken with
very odd messages
um so I suggest we treat this as a
documentation bug and I have a suggested
new note on
alternatives to replace the uh current
one where is that on Alternatives in uh
yeah yeah I can bring it up
I think that's fine
okay
I mean it's obscure but it's fine
okay
so this is another primary documentation
meeting so the documentation the main
usage for default values currently says
that it gives the transformation rules
of default
um but actually it turns out it actually
gives the both the transformation rules
for default and transformation rules for
options if there are any
um
which uh you know this has always been
the behavior and uh you know again I
have some suggested well they're
actually Ian and I each had
independently had made different
suggestions for the new usage
um
so you can so I thought well we should
just make it short and then use the
notes to clarify what it is and Ian went
with the option of well we should go
along and make the main usage
um
so you're saying that if I have
gosh I can't remember how once the
options of app right so if you say
options of f equals a goes to B and then
look at the fault values of f then you
will see a rule for a hold pattern of
options of f that's funky
yeah it's a little funky
this is very
you know anti-diluvian code
and
I mean the default concept
did not turn out to be as useful as I
thought it would be
well I mean you're just documenting it
to be correct basically correct
I think that's the thing to do I
wouldn't muddy the the stuff at the Top
If you can avoid it
okay so just make the you go with what's
currently the second usage note in that
list of five which it makes it short and
then use the notes to expand what
default values I think so yeah
I think I think this is a corner case
okay and the um yeah I I did put this
additional question there at the bottom
of you know in various places for
example the usage message of down values
that uses down values all lower case one
word which seems a little odd shouldn't
it be two words a thief camel cased it
and I don't know if that's like an
accident I don't know you don't know
that's really from
just antiquity
um I mean
I think we've always used down values
we've used it so long it's become a word
for us even though it wasn't a word when
it was first used I don't know how we
deal with that I mean it's like web page
or you know web page now probably is one
word a website is now definitely one
word and it used to not be one word
so we we hung ourselves here because
you know down values used to be two
words but then we kind of made it a
one-word thing
okay well just you know then I think we
should just leave the inconsistency it's
a weird thing but I think okay assistant
across all the values functions right so
so then the so so then our our our uh
our consistency rule is as a function
name it's camel case in text it's all
lowercase one word yeah I think so okay
all right so this is one of these things
that's going to be
horrifying a little horrifying although
not I mean this is not entirely an even
or arguably even mostly our fault
um
right so so the behavior on on Unix file
systems is right right a file has one or
more links and you know when it the link
count gets to zero then it you know it's
quote unquote deleted and it's possible
to change the lean count while a stream
is open
um and so this uh
um you know leads to various odd
behaviors which uh the link count is
basically an inode no what what I
explained yes it's an entry in the inode
of how many hard links point to this
inode
okay
right and so maybe just going through
the examples will sort of make this
clear so if you write to a file and then
an external process deletes it then it
looks like everything is getting written
normally but then when you see it's
written it in outer space when it will
be garbage collected by the file system
eventually exactly and and there are no
warnings because according to the you
know posix that's not an error you can
write to something with the link count
of zero
um
right now if you know and again like I
said there are different behaviors so if
you write to a file and while it's open
you close it you use delete file on it
well delete file has the good sense to
close the stream before you you know
before it actually changes the link it
closes all streams that were open known
to our system that we're open to that it
closes the particular stream that it's
closed the of if there's a stream
associated with the file it's been asked
to delete it closes that string okay
and so you know so then basically you'll
see after you call delete file you'll
get the expected behavior of it will
create a new file with the contents
um and of course the tour de force is
where rename file right so if you use
rename file and you move it across the
same partition then you get more
messages and you know you won't see it
at the old location but at the new youth
location you'll see everything including
the stuff you've been writing to it
right from you move it across file
systems your your toast it's going to be
writing off into La La Land
correct
brilliant
um and so then the question is you know
or a question is what can or should we
do to improve this situation so this has
been reported
um both externally and you know a couple
of times uh internally I think to be to
be perfectly honest I think some of
those internal reports are are from
people who are writing sloppy code
because if they actually close their
streams when they were done with them
they wouldn't run into this issue but
how does this relate to locking
um how does this relate to locking
um
so locking says
I don't know how locking affects
I think locking creates links to files
um Chris do you know
you'll probably I know that you can
create locked you can there's like a
lock
you can like locks that you can put on
files
in posix right
um and I've tried that with this case
right and of course that doesn't affect
that wouldn't prevent you from unlinking
it
and you can kind of put a lock on a
directory as well one type of lock but I
also tested that and you could still
remove like a file from the directory so
if you're talking about like operating
system Lots
I don't think that that could help right
because operating system logs prevent
multiple processes from writing to it at
the same time
but I don't know that they yeah okay but
they don't affect whether you can move
it or things okay what does what does a
piece of C code do in this case it just
goes blurup basically right it well it
right it basically calls right right so
uh in culturite uh or F right
technically and yeah writes into just
this disembodied file that doesn't that
is that will never be seen again right
and no
no uh
um
yeah I right I guess if you know the
inode of the file you might be able to
read those contents
to closing the stream but the moment you
close the stream then it's garbage
collected right so F right never get
doesn't mean it might not be garbage
collected but it is marked for garbage
collection correct
and so I think this is just a feature of
files and this is like this is so deep
inside the I there's nothing we can do
about this is there
right we know it happened can we can we
okay
when we write to a file can we do
something I don't know where the F stat
I don't remember always functions but is
there some way of figuring out uh what
whether whether we're in a disembodied
whether we're in a black hole so to
speak
I think so that sort of option one that
maybe when we write we check the link
count and if it's zero we issue a
message saying dude yeah right
that seems like a sensible thing to do
is there any other serious alternative
um
there well Chris made this some proposal
which wasn't entirely fleshed out so
maybe if he thinks it's a serious
proposal he can speak for it which was
that close could return something
special if the file was delete deleted
or moved in the process
but I don't think that yeah
I think my the bigger part of what I was
trying to say was that we could just do
nothing because you know like it's like
has been said you know it's just file
system see you know it's not gonna if
you do F right on some disembodied you
know uh stream it's not gonna tell you
so I think it's acceptable
that when you're trying to write to a
file a right string or something it
doesn't tell you anything
I think that's fine I don't think we
necessarily even want that to be noisy
in this case and like uh I tried
different programming languages you know
like on python Java and they don't for
this similar similar things obviously
happen
in those contexts as well
and like on writing I wasn't getting it
it wasn't completely let's let's
investigate the following thing is there
a trivial fast system call that can find
this link count on every right and can
just generate a message if the if the
link count is zero
we could do that
if that's fast we should do it if it
isn't fast we should punt
okay
right and I also you know just because
of
uh
you know these reports I I raised a
question in which is my fourth bullet
point which is do we need to better
document the fact that you need to close
streams when you're done right I mean
there is a note on like right that it
doesn't close the streams that open uh
um but I don't know that well this is a
code assistance type thing that you know
being able to look at code and say this
never closed that stream would be a
useful thing
that's where I would put it on the on
the static analysis side
um
but
was I going to say
um
yeah giving a message on close is I
think not a good idea it's kind of like
something terrible happened an hour ago
sorry we didn't tell you about it then
now you've just lost all your data bye
yeah
um
right yeah that's my middle bullet point
there possibly this comes too late and
and I was trying to be generous so
right I think that let's try and figure
out whether we can do it on right and if
we can great and you know if that's too
inefficient then we'll have to punt
okay there's kind of yeah it's kind of
obnoxious a little bit that on every
right you're getting uh a message I
think that would be the only thing what
do you mean it's only a message if it's
just you know if something went horribly
wrong
we're only saying you give a right you
give a message if the file has zero link
count
yeah
but nobody else from what we've tested
kind of seems like not
that that's not something that other
people don't
just means there are bugs in other
people's programs
yeah and I mean it's not right
how could it possibly if you get another
stream reading
say that again yes I see you could have
a stream you could have a reading but we
don't have read write streams we don't
if we had read write streams this would
be
um more complicated question right so we
need to put a note in the code where we
add this that says if we have read write
streams ever we've been meaning to have
them for 30 years and we haven't had
them yet so I'm not holding my breath
but if we have rewrite streams then we
need to change the scripture in and it
needs to look and see whether there's a
read stream that's been opened as well
and then not print this
Chris does that make sense to you
yeah but it's not just our system right
somebody else could have be reading from
the file have a stream that's open
that's reading from the file
and then it's not lost
until I see I see I see I see I see I
see okay so you're saying I guess this
is a scenario I haven't imagined so we
opened a stream for writing some other
process opens it for reading and even if
it's deleted as long as the other
process opened it streamed before
if the file was deleted it will still
see our rights until
you know until okay I got a compromise
okay why don't we generate a message the
first time this happens to a file
the first time the file was moved or
deleted
if there are a thousand rights to that
same file we don't generate a message
subsequently we just do it the first
time
yeah that's I think that's possible I'm
sure it's possible to store that
information in the file structure
right
um I mean we do have obviously some
metadata associated with the streams so
the question is do we have some place to
store it uh I think the answer is yes
but I mean that would be my suggestion
for a compromise Chris what do you think
of that
I think that's that could be workable I
mean one thing to note is that on moving
right that's harder to detect
right the only time that would affect
the link count is when it's moved to a
different file system
I mean the fact that the file moved
right yes I mean you you said on on
delete or move but you know in in crisp
speak that's if the if the link count
reaches zero I mean that's really the
condition that we care about yep
all right let's try going on that path
it will save somebody one day will thank
us very much for putting in that message
yeah like the external person who
reported this issue
yeah for example or you know I'm sure
it's bitten me in the past I never
really thought about it properly
okay
right I mean we we can definitely look
at you know those four specific things
but I mean there is sort of the bigger
point of you know
and and I have opinions about these four
specific guys
um
but
um
you know there there's also a question
of right I mean we can spend and right
we have 5 000 symbols we can spend an
infinite amount of time adding operator
forms uh
so maybe you know what we need yeah
we need a right-click menu that says
look up and help
um
we don't have that we should have it
yeah that's interesting
uh it might be worth having but the
keystroke is is easier anyway
but that I don't know that is sort of
shocking it's because I don't usually do
this for non-code type things
I mean it's faster than pressing the
little pop-up thing as well but yeah if
I just need the user's message I'll use
shift command K to to look at the
templates but if I want the uh
the uh the actual help page then it's
shift command f
M all right my attitude towards this is
if you think about natural language and
you think about cases in which there are
like intransitive versions of verbs or
something like that
you know whether it's both transitive
and intransitive for example it's kind
of like when you can get away with it
you do it and when you can't you don't
know that sentence did not parse at all
for me
that's probably because it had one of
those optional and transitive verbs
um no I mean
what I'm saying is I think
the the
the threshold should be high because we
don't want to put in an operator form
and then regret it
because we blow away some other
possibility
but my feeling is in a case like split
by I don't see why we shouldn't have an
operator for and we're never going to
want to one argument form
I don't see why we shouldn't have an
operator form there
'll be my statement and similarly Gather
By I would say the buy functions will be
a very reasonable place to have operator
forms
which would have more or less been my
position because I like group by for
example has an operator form so then y
doesn't Gather By yeah
if you now of course can you tell me off
the top of your head what's the
difference between Group by and Gather
By
um yes one of the Mexican Association
one of them doesn't okay
Group by Mexican Association Gather By
just makes lists okay see I have used
these functions excellent now take while
I mean I suppose I can't but we don't
really do any of these right none of
these like none of these wild things
have options I don't think that's right
to do that I mean I think that um uh
yeah take while seems like a very
procedural I mean I know it really is a
functional construct but it feels kind
of procedural
maybe it's just because it has wild in
the name
yeah I just don't see it
I mean is Nest I I just don't see it I
don't see this
does Nest have an operator form no no
that was the first thing I checked
uh
I mean it could have one
we're cutting you off
what
[Laughter]
what would it be I mean it would be F
comma FN of x no it's like it's like yes
F of f n of X bar
it's kind of like it's it's kind of cool
actually I mean it's like the the nth
power
of
F applied to expert
I mean I said oh so so an operator form
would have two arguments pronounced yes
yeah okay
and they're not consecutive
having done that before Stephen we're
definitely cutting you off
what do you mean having done that before
which is no fun to implement I don't
remember but I know I did it
apply maybe I don't remember but it
shouldn't be hard to implement but the
operator form for for fold just takes F
at the beginning and then the additional
argument
goes in the second bracket
well you know I was going to say if we
have it for nest what would we do for
fold because fold already has a two
argument form and a three argument form
and a new X comma range of 10.
it's a little funky it's just strange
it is strange
is it documented yeah
I mean this one I can really see take
while I'm
gosh that's pretty weird
what the heck just happened here hello
did I lose you all no you're here we're
here
that was just absolutely weird my screen
I didn't notice a lapse uh the what was
it was it the help browser or to write
something in the rest of your screen
that went funky because I think that
this just changed the
wow something really weird happened here
well never mind
I think it's something went full screen
that wasn't full screen and it just oh
wow okay any case
let me just see what I can pull up the
hot browser now might not be possible
no that's opening in some in some
invisible screen now
well I'm a one window
I'm I'm restricted to one window now
well you can always uh
open the option inspector and forcibly
move the the window if it's something
somewhere okay but or you could go to
the window menu and select the window
well it won't help if it's if it's you
know like if it's coordinates are such
that it's actually off screen yeah it's
off screen oh but now press command W to
close it
well it's selected
like if you if you press
Mathematica window press the window you
want to destroy and then press command w
okay but that doesn't do me any good if
I can't open another one well try it
uh I get I think how browser is designed
to remember its last position
oh no I think you really wanted to bug
it you can probably go help
documentation to open another
documentation window kill the one off
screen and you know
oh wow what's that
uh suspicious a very compact yet knew
you already had one open so it decided
to open in very compact form right
something's deeply confused okay no
matter
um
I think we should do the buy functions
I think we should not we should hold on
the other ones okay I think that Nest f
comren is interesting and probably we
should just try and think through what
consequences that would have
okay
um
all right so somebody
um
maybe make them a ticket or do we need
it even we have these in uh suggestion
reports right so you you can close you
can just close the T the Wild Ones is
disagree with suggestion and you know
just do the other two you know split by
gather bye all right are there other buy
functions that we haven't handled yet
uh I suppose we can do a question mark
about a star by and see
um
confirmed by doesn't have one although
there's been a suggestion I mean there
have been various ideas about having
operator forms for lots of confirmed
functions but it requires some thought
but won't doesn't that I mean aren't the
confirmed by hold and won't that destroy
their wholeness that that seems like
it's uh
yeah that's right that was that was one
of the issues yeah you're right okay
there are a bunch that are just
rearrangement type things and those can
be I can have an operator form I think
although we have to look at every single
one of them but I think these ones I
mean this whole business about know
about sub values not being able to be
held it's possible one day we should
address that as Sue
anybody want to comment on that I mean
is it is that addressable by a sub-value
hold attribute that the evaluator could
see
um
in principle I think yes
um you know what sort of effort I I
can't claim to know the implementation
of devaluator well enough to comment on
if there are serious conceptual
difficulties or you know how much effort
that would be uh you know we could I
would speculate that it is neither
conceptually difficult nor that much
effort relative to all the other things
because I would speculate that it knows
the head of the head of the head
it's going to overclust down to the head
of the head of the head and so it could
store that information out well well it
does it does kind of so I I looked into
this once
um and and you know I I know nothing I
know available how the evaluator works
and I was totally confused looking at it
but I mean one of the things is that
function already does this
so because you can get function a third
argument to set the attributes for it
and then it will have effectively hold
all sub values
so there's some carve out in in the you
know in the evaluator that was just
super obscure and I didn't understand
that handled this
why don't we look at this that you're
right that there must be something for
the function case
maybe we just never thought it was
important enough and we just weren't
doing enough operator forms to occur
I think we should look at this this
issue does come up a lot though yeah it
does there are lots of places where we
would have liked to have done a design
that used sub values because sub values
are a creature of the last decade or so
or so in terms of widespread use
right but now what would it be there'd
be hold all sub values hold first sub
values hold all sub values complete or
what would it be or would it just be one
of them you just have you know one of
them I would think but I mean you know
that might be where we would start and
then maybe later on we'd need other ones
but I mean I think initially it would
just behold the sub values because the
hold all the sub values
because remember it's going to be the
head of the head of the head
again I guess well I mean I guess one
question is would we want
to hold the sub values without holding
the arguments itself in which
yes I think so
yeah like their operator forms where you
want that
okay
um
right and I I well
foreign
look I mean we've got this case we've
got I mean I think it can get quite
hairy I mean we've got a case like this
and then do you hold both Y and Z I
think the answer is yes because the
notion of firstness
is no longer do not get what I'm saying
I mean
right it's first like first level of
sadness or first level of or first
argument in the sub-value thing yep
um and I think the only plausible thing
to do is just hold them all
and then let the function because if you
held them the function can always decide
to evaluate them
right and they don't
right I guess the only
right the only
possible for right so for most purposes
um
you know complete versus not complete
wouldn't make a difference
um
the real except for if you start
inserting sequences right I think that's
going to be the only
but I mean we could certainly start with
the
not complete uh this would be quite
transformative for a bunch of design
issues we've had
it will be very very helpful to be able
to do this
let's look at it I really hadn't
remembered the function case
I suspect this is a Tom question
yes all right here let me let me well uh
Devin Sent send me an email today or to
well wait what day is today today is
Thursday send me an email before this is
over to add this to my sticky note for
my meeting with Tom and I will ask him
tomorrow
by the way today's Wednesday
isn't that what I said oh you said
Thursday but that's okay yes well today
is the day before Thursday which is why
a note today would be helpful an email
today would be helpful for my meeting on
Thursday with Tom there you go yes I
will do that
um
okay anything else we have to cover in
this meeting
um I mean do we want to look at some of
those buys I think I think most of those
we actually do have Opera let's take a
look okay let's take a look
yep operator form
operator form
operator form
that's on the list yep
yep
and I use that one quite a bit
oh nope okay all right let's look at
ordering by
that might be motivated by the fact that
it's you know a lot of the common usages
are multi-argument
yeah it's just an oversight split by I
think
ordering by a reverse sort by sort by or
a team a trio
oh take larger space seems to be one
where we insert something in the middle
and take smallest by
right
yeah okay
pure operator reform right
yes I believe that's correct I was
saying that times by I believe is a pure
operator form
why do you say that that's not right
times by something completely different
it's a side effect oh it's that one okay
oh
because I I feel like I was fooled by
that too
okay I feel like we also added a a
something
is it multiplied by I no there isn't
that I feel like we added something that
was a pure right right precisely because
we couldn't
you know use Times by right and times as
far R so it can't be an operator form I
feel like we then we add some we did
like equal to
yes or same as also yeah operator only
forms that were replacements
right but we didn't do that for basic
arithmetic is what you're telling me
which is
oh we want it for basic arithmetic I
mean it's I see it it's a thing that is
a multiplied by multiplied by this
right just like we have greater than
which is the operator form of Greater
which is used in like yeah entity
computations right it's a predicate but
I don't know why we want it as an action
I mean threaded
does some of the things perhaps let's
just look at our ordering by hold on one
second
well I mean the obvious operator for me
the one argument version
I mean look it doesn't seem crazy to
have ordering by of f
as an operator form
yeah the
remember we're we're doing it for all
three then if we do it for one
but all three Watts sort by and reverse
sort by that's already in there
oh
I missed that yeah it's in all of them
it's in all of them except ordering by
and okay these other ones where we
missed it
that's sorted by I'm less familiar with
but otherwise operator form oh okay yeah
then it should be an ordering by I'll
add that too okay fine yep all right
all right well it looks like I
underprepared I I did have to to
substitute one agenda item for another
one that would definitely have been a
lot longer discussion so what was it for
underestimating what were we missing
uh it was a
it was a discussion about
um
like you know if you get have some
property that can be a quantity like how
can you get it as a quantity or as a
number in particular units or things
like that okay but it was sort of a big
mess and and not everyone was available
and and so rather than having a bad
discussion I substituted this topic
which clearly with the other ones also
going short this did not fill out a full
agenda so sorry about that I'll I'll
I guess we'll come in short uh one of
these meetings as opposed to our normal
ex you know right by 30 minutes
fine okay well let's declare Victory
then um all right all right thanks
everyone thanks so much time bye bye